did you hear about that Jungle Cruise
ride breaking down I guess that ride
isn't rock solid
Wow that's what I was gonna say that's a
kind of annoying you just took my line
oh and you're annoyed you're really
blunt about it oh I'm Craig Angie's 15
years I need a new friend
yeah actually almost 15 years oh boy
we're gonna watch the trailer a fish
someone for Jungle Cruise I know this
came out a few hours ago specifically
waited to cover this with Ashley because
she went on the set for this movie
that's right she's the lead in it yeah I
wish in Hawaii I did go to the set
though and it was really cool they built
the entire set just for this the whole
jungle water area was built just for
this Wow it's like Disney has money tied
up whoa let's watch this trailer
[Music]
[Music]
skipper kasi Lemmons
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you see wants to kill you
whoa
oh dude don't want to feed up an animal
summary to the
[Applause]
[Music]
I like this swashbuckle a music
this looks like Pirates of the Caribbean
[Music]
that looks so fun yeah that looks like a
blast this is the first trailer you've
seen of it you said another yeah Wow how
does this one compare to that one well
this one gives you more footage yeah
this one gives you a more detailed
version of the plot they're looking for
this special tree she has the hidden key
there's a lot of vibes that seem a lot
like a whole bunch of other movies and
that's not necessarily a bad thing
because you got some of the flare of
that Brendan Fraser racial vice version
of the mummy a little bit of the
contrast with Dwayne Johnson Johnson
Emily Blunt yeah and then you got a
little bit of being higher to the
Caribbean some of Jumanji there's Annie
Tarzan yes great call like the villain
kinda reminds you of Clayton yeah the
guys with your British accent yes
exactly and then you know come on Dwayne
Johnson's a beast am i right exactly
they're swinging on vines yeah there's
like a little bit of that like
swashbuckling old flare of a film like
Romancing the Stone so you got a whole
bunch of different vibes here and it
looks like it's all correlating to be a
really fun family swashbuckling
adventure if you ask me hey looks super
fun but his Jungle Cruise based on like
the ride at Disneyland ethology
oh is it no they had a like come up with
the storyline pretty much just based on
this boat that takes you around in the
jungle
yeah and five seconds of this trailer is
a million times more exciting than that
ride that ride needs an update for sure
yeah
especially because it broke down yeah I
mean I feel like after this movie comes
out they probably will update it like
the way Hank Johnson in the back and
they're gonna like probably add some
stuff right yeah the way how that parts
of the Caribbean has like 45 Johnny
Depp's appearing exactly I'll do that
with a whole bunch of Dwayne Johnson's
yeah
Oh that'll be so fun I think I only went
on that ride for the first time back in
December those first two yeah at first
it's cool but it is flare not at all
it's kind of like you don't really want
to travel to the Amazon here's some
animatronic
it was a skipper is that the tour guides
name the script that they have I can see
some of that sarcastic wick that they
brought here for Dwayne Johnson's
character sure they wanted to make sure
they really honor the tour guide it's a
Disneyland for sure who plays her
brother in it because I heard a rumor on
set was that he was like amazing and so
hilarious and like stole the show but I
didn't see him in this trailer
her brother yeah whoever plays her
brother based off of the name
correlation I'm gonna assume it's Jack
Whitehall from Bad Education and
Mother's Day I didn't see him at the
trailer though did you
no I didn't but I did see Jesse Plemons
so I think is a him so he's the bad guy
apparently I love when he plays like
eccentric weird characters I think he's
actually a really underrated comedy
actor okay thank you he stole the show
and oh my god if he was my favorite in
that absolutely stole the show apologia
Mahdi's in this movie but I think you've
met once I have I have yes I hear he's a
gentle fellow but he wasn't in the
trailer either I know man they're
chipping you on we're missing a lot of
these people what the kids want is some
Paul Giamatti action damn it every
child's like where's my Giamatti I think
a lot of the production design does look
great it does feel very reminiscent of
Pirates of the Caribbean specially Dead
Man's Chest yes sure and like when he's
playing the guitar in this beginning
piece it kind of just looks like almost
like the blue by you know when you go
into the Blue Bayou wrecks the Caribbean
kinda has that feel to it this actually
looks like they filmed in a Disney away
yeah I think the costume designs
production design is great some of the
CGI this is kind of a common complaint
that I've been having with a lot of
movies some of the CGI and the animals
doesn't look entirely believable
especially what my girlfriend's gonna
kill me on this that's either a leopard
or a cheetah or a tiger
[Music]
she's like a huge cheetah lover so if
that's a cheetah I didn't get her I
don't think it's a cheetah but that just
does not look very real but then again
if Dwayne Johnson's gonna be like
beating the crap out of an animal in a
movie it's best to have a look as fake
as possible I suppose that's true but
then again would I make him a little bit
unlikable even if the animals like
threatening and lethal
why don't you still be like hmm I don't
want to see him hit an animal because
looks like he's gonna punch that animal
right in the face it does look like that
for sure Pete is gonna get involved in
this movie we have the costumes looks
super good the makeup the makeup
especially we're not gonna name drop
here we know someone who did the makeup
for this movie he doesn't watch the
channel yeah this looks like a total
blast I'm excited for it I think it's
gonna be a hoot of a time and of course
the chemistry between James Blunt and
Emily Blunt between Emily Blunt and
Dwayne Johnson does look really she's
adorable did you meet her no wow what a
waste of time I was very upset I didn't
get to meet the rock either well you
should talk to the makeup guy that we're
talking about I should and tell him that
he owes you yeah but I heard he was
super sweet I heard they are all awesome
awesome well the rock will be cooking at
the box office this summer interacting
with jungles and animals that is the
rocks typecasting right there do you
think there's gonna be a second one if
it makes money there's definitely gonna
be a second is it feels like this
totally could like he's like Jumanji or
parts the Caribbean like it just feels
like a sequel kind of like a franchise
film yeah I think they're definitely
aiming for that yeah and let's hope he
gets there because if not I'm gonna be
very disappointed plus we need our
makeup friend to keep making some money
yeah we need to go to the set on the
second one yeah that's why that's all
right guys well what did you think of
this Jungle Cruise trailer leave your
thoughts down below subscribe to the
reel rejects click that notification
bell
Ashley ender is on Instagram posing an
appropriate clothing a lot
point that out listen this is a JN
Valente J and Valente is our patron who
I say always messes me with the
stream-of-consciousness type of mindset
so I wrote him a Greg poem here we go
first letters J man's a big crear gonna
look directly I mean this whole time
straighter gay doesn't matter which way
he sways just hope at our patreon he
always stays second letter n emerges
from the lion's den that's dargas kylo
Ren I'll obey your Commandments all ten
of them last name Valente let's have a
three-way take your messages turn them
into dialogue into a screenplay
introduced me to knots for a to where is
he from I don't know maybe but not to
then you ought to can take a while to
respond but what do you respond to
salaam goes above and beyond to you I'll
forever be fond to read your stream of
consciousness words are vomitus and
bottomless and certainly never
monotonous you're quite the muse in this
ain't no ruse paint me like a French
lady on a Jungle Cruise you needed like
all the lights to go off in just one
spotlight on you for that that would
have been really cool I don't like to
put that much